alors moi je suis en pleine réflexion
sur le retour définitif
oui définitif enfin ça vous puissiez pas
peur vous le retour définitif moi c'est
vrai que le termine stress alors c'est
comme si on vous disait attention vous
allez rentrer et vous allez plus jamais
en ressortir
ça me fait penser au programme mars one
ya des gens qui se portent volontaires
pour aller vivre sur mars dans dix ans
et ces gens là oui ils ont un ticket
aller sans retour
ces gens là ne pourront plus jamais
revenir sur terre donc là oui je suis
d'accord on peut parler de définitif et
puis je me suis dit pourquoi nous les
tunisiens on parle de ce terme pourquoi
on utilise ce terme
enfin j'ai jamais entendu un étranger ou
un français qui vient en tunisie dur
ouais moi je réfléchis aux recrues
définitivement en france
et puis je me suis dit non ce terme en
fait j'ai appris qu'ils venaient de il
avait une histoire qui venait et qui
venait de voilà que qui n'étaient pas
utilisés denis parent est en fait ce
terme là vient des années 70 en fait en
1973 la france
crise pétrolière chômage voulaient que
les étrangers leur a proposé en tout cas
une procédure de départs volontaires et
cette procédure de départs volontaires
en fait les étrangers déclarés leur
retour définitif il recevait une
indemnité et rendez leur papier et à
cette époque en 1973 ou dans les années
70 ça voulait vraiment dire quelque
chose la communication les transports cc
c'est pas la même chose qu'aujourd'hui
donc s'avère vraiment un sens et je me
suis dit qu'est ce que ça signifie pour
moi aujourd'hui familles tunisiennes de
30 ans ce terme de retour définitif
alors moi et à 12 ans j'ai
j'étais à cette époque en train de
préparer le bac j'allais je me préparais
surtout à quitter tunis et à partir à
paris
quand je me souviens de cette
effervescence du départ ce stress
mélanger dedans vie en fait pour moi
paris c'était le rêve c'était les
terrasses étaient le théâtre c'était la
bohème et puis en même temps j'étais
j'étais stressé j'avais peur j'avais
peur de quitter tunis
j'avais peur de quitter ma famille
j'avais peur de quitter certains amis et
donc voilà donc c'était c'était vraiment
un sentiment étrange
et aujourd'hui quand je quand je
réfléchis au retour définitif en tunisie
en fait j'ai eu le même sentiment
j'ai peur je me suis dit est-ce que je
suis la seule à avoir peur parce que je
vois des gens qui sont très
enthousiastes eux ils savent y est j'ai
la nationalité je vais rentrer en
tunisie
et puis donc je me suis dit bon enfin je
me suis fait faire une étude je vais
faire un sondage
et puis je leur ai demandé est ce que
vous envisagez de rentrer en tunisie
alors il ya ceux qui sont déjà rentrés
qui sont très satisfaits donc déjà c'est
rassurant et puis est ce qu'ils disent
oui je veux entrer mais à long terme
à long terme je sais pas vous mais moi
ça veut dire un peu tout et n'importe
quoi
c'est comme moi qui ai fait la finance
de marché qu'ils aient oui je vais
rentrer à long terme en tunisie sans fin
ça veut surtout dire je veux pas me
prendre la tête
et puis je leur ai dit pourquoi rentrer
et dans ce pour quoi rentrer hormis les
raisons habituelles les raisons
personnelles en fait j'ai de nouvelles
via une nouvelle variable dans
l'équation
il ya une nouvelle variable c'est rentré
en tunisie pour la révolution parce
qu'il ya eu une révolution dans notre
pays parce qu'il ya une effervescence
d'opportunités parce qu'on veut
construire la tunisie de demain
et en même temps en fait ce dont je me
suis rendu compte que ces gens là ont
aussi des craintes alors bon ma cité la
sécurité c'est vrai qu'en tunisie on a
vu des choses qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir avant on a parlé de
liberté
alors moi j'ai dit mais pourquoi on
parle de liberté on a quand même fait
une révolution pour être libre ça
devrait plus être un problème
on m'a parlé
et de bureaucratie bon c'est anecdotique
mais bon on connaît tous le fameux app
genre doit revient demain de la
bureaucratie tunisienne et voilà mais
ces gens là ont aussi des envies parce
que quand on se réveille à paris à 8
heures du matin qui fait noir keep le
consulat plus pour lé travail et on se
dit mais qu'est-ce que je fais là
pourquoi je suis pas au soleil à tunis
avec ma famille et voilà donc autre
chose
aujourd'hui ce que j'ai même remarqué
dans cette étude c'est que les tunisiens
de l'étranger se sentent entre deux
chaises ils se sentent entre deux
chaises ils sont le produit de deux
sociétés parce que quand je leur ai
donné une baguette magique et que je
leur ai dit si vous aviez une baguette
magique qu'est ce que vous feriez alors
il y en a qui m'ont dit je veux faire un
mélange de la france et de la tunisie
d'autres m'ont dit je veux transformer
tunis en singapour de la méditerranée je
sais pas si vous avez vu singapour et
puis en a qui m'ont dit encore plus
étrange
on m'a dit je veux injecté le dévouement
que les japonais ont dans leur
dévouement dans leur travail dans le
cerveau des tunisiens est ce que vous
savez qu'il ya une loi qui est sorti en
japon pour obliger les japonais à
prendre les vacances je sais pas quand
est-ce que ça va arriver en tunisie
enfin bon tout ça pour dire que nous
sommes aujourd'hui un mélange de deux
sociétés
parce que quand on vit à l'étranger dix
ans ou plus ou moins même en fait on
acquiert des valeurs la guerre surtout
une échelle de valeur on acquiert un
nouveau code de société on apprend de
nouveaux codes et donc quand on parle de
retour en tunisie on va devoir se
réadapter en fait à notre code de
société initial a ses repères que l'on
avait initialement mais dans l'échelle
de valeur qu'on a acquis dans les codes
qu'ont acquis à l'étranger
il ya des choses qui nous sont chères
qui nous sont chères et qu'on risque de
ne pas retrouver forcément en tunisie et
donc
la phrase qui était la plus parlante
pour moi en tout cas celle que je
ressens c'est j'ai changé et je veux
changer les choses en tunisie je dois y
contribuer c'est ma seule motivation
je veux que mes enfants soient fiers de
leur pays
alors voilà nous sommes un mélange de
deux sociétés et quand on parle de
changement le grand changement qui a
tout bousculé changé même ce concept
même de retour définitif c'est la
révolution la révolution tout est
nouveau tout est possible on n'a plus de
limites on a plus de barrières et à plus
de plafond de verre aujourd'hui on peut
faire des choses en tunisie aujourd'hui
on peut construire la tunisie de demain
mais quand je pense à ça avec toute
cette cette envie cette effervescence je
pense aussi que nous en fait cette
génération nous sommes aujourd'hui les
bâtisseurs de la tunisie pour la future
génération
nous sommes aujourd'hui ce qu'ils vont
vraiment nous investir nous battre au
quotidien pour défendre des valeurs pour
construire une tunisie dont nous serons
fiers et donc en fait ça me fait penser
à la génération dans un tout autre
concept dans un tout autre contexte des
générations des bâtisseurs de dubaï
c'est complètement différent mais quand
la génération des bâtisseurs de dubaï on
peut se demander s'ils ont vraiment
profité du dubaï qu'on voit aujourd'hui
et qu'on n'a pas besoin de vous décrire
ils ont travaillé à la sueur de leur
front pour construire en tout cas un
lieu où se sentent bien aujourd'hui dans
la question du retour définitif
on peut se poser cette question est-ce
que moi aujourd'hui j'ai envie de me
battre de l'intérieur est ce que j'ai
envie aujourd'hui de construire la
tunisie de demain de tunis parce qu'on
peut le faire de l'étranger
ça ne veut pas dire que parce qu'on est
à l'étranger qu'on ne
pas concernés par notre pays au
contraire le jour où il ya eu la
révolution je pense qu'on était tous
scotchés est tous frustrés à ses dires
mais est ce qui se passe je suis pas et
et au final il ya un million ou plus
d'un million de tunisiens on n'est que
11 millions et on se dit voilà il ya des
investissements qui sont possibles
associatif il ya les projets qu'on peut
faire en tunisie
donc la question qu'on se pose quand on
doit rentrer en tunisie est ce que j'ai
envie de me battre de l'intérieur
localement en changeant ma résidence et
puis quand je pense à la femme
quand je pense à la tunisie à la
révolution je pense à la femme
tunisienne
je pensais la fine cuisine parce qu'on
est tellement fier à l'étranger alors
moi c'était un sujet sur lequel il
fallait pas me lancer
dd oui la femme tunisienne c'est une
femme forte c'est une femme moderne nous
en tunisie on a eu le droit de vote
avant la femme suisse donc on est
l'exception du monde arabe
je leur parlais de notre héritage je
leur parlais de parade est qui déjà dans
les années 30 se battait pour la femme
tunisienne il en avait fait son combat
entre autres et il avait déjà abordé à
l'époque à travers sa lecture moderne du
coran les questions de la polygamie les
questions du voile les questions du
divorce les questions enfin bref
beaucoup de questions qu'on se pose même
aujourd'hui dans notre société
et puis ensuite ça a été repris à
travers le code du statut personnel en
1956 et puis je me dis il ya aussi quand
même à un paradoxe c'est un paradoxe
parce que entre cette fierté des
musiques démesurées et entre la réalité
on peut se dire qu'il ya des il ya une
fille un paradoxe quand je pense que ces
quatre dernières années la femme
tunisienne a été au centre d'un débat
pour être complémentaire de l'homme
c'est un débat qui aujourd'hui ne
devrait même pas avoir lieu
et aujourd'hui on a dit on a proposé de
la femme soit complémentaire de l'homme
alors je me dis que rien est acquis que
tout cet héritage mais heureusement ça a
été c'est pas passé mais tout cet
héritage
on peut pas
mais pas en débattre et je me demande
surtout quand est ce que toutes les
femmes de toutes les sauces de toutes
les classes sociales de toutes les
régions en tunisie auront le droit de
choisir librement leur mode de vie et
donc aujourd'hui on ne peut pas se poser
la question du retour définitif en tant
que femme tunisienne sans se dire moi si
je rentre en tunisie
je vais me battre au quotidien même par
des actions simples pas forcément en le
criant tous les jours mais même par beau
départ des actions simples pour se
battre pour notre pour nos droits pour
faire évoluer certaines mentalités pour
faire évoluer nos droits qui était une
avancée incroyable à l'époque mais on a
toujours des choses à faire sur ce sujet
et donc c'est une question qui se pose
est parmi toutes ces questions qui se
posent au sein même de la question du
retour définitif
ces pardons
c est ce que aujourd'hui comment je vais
résoudre cette question comment je vais
prendre une décision alors moi je me
suis dit je vais puiser ça peut-être
dans mon travail vu que c'est rationnel
je me suis dit je vais je veux faire
peut-être est un contrat en comparatif
est donc aujourd'hui moi je suis risk
manager donc je travaille dans les
métiers de l'investissement en gestion
d'actifs et aujourd'hui on fait de la
gestion de conviction la gestion de
conviction croit en un marché en croit
en une valeur mais aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas se dire oui j'y crois
et puis je vais mettre tout mon argent
dessus et puis advienne que pourra
non aujourd'hui on a des risques on a
des limites de risque qui contrôle tout
ça est donc je vais par exemple
lorsqu'on va ouvrir un fond on a des
limites pre trade on a des limites post
trade à la limite très traite par
exemple qui interdisent la vente à
découvert est dans les mythes traiterait
de l'ordre le l'ordre ne passe pas si le
giron veut passer une vente à découvert
l'ordre ne passe pas et puis aller et
puis il ya les
limite post trade alors ça les postes
rsa se déroule autrement par exemple un
client va vous dire pour un fonds dédié
moi je ne veux pas m'investir à plus de
30% sur la dette émergente et le jour où
par des fluctuations de marché ou par un
ordre
cet ordre cette limite est dépassée
dans ce cas là on va avertir le gérant
pour réajuster son ordre mais aussi une
fois l'ordre ajusté on peut se poser la
question est ce qu'aujourd'hui avec la
stratégie cette limite convient toujours
est-ce qu'on peut modifier cette limite
aujourd'hui le gérant peut nous dire non
moins aujourd'hui dans le cadre de ma
stratégie je veux aller à 25% et donc ça
va on va demander aux clients son avis
et puis il va nous dire s'ils le
souhaitent ou non
donc au final c'est pareil pour le
retour définitif
aujourd'hui on va si on va se fixer des
limites il faut qu'on connaisse nos
limites il faut qu'on menace nos lignes
rouges
il faut qu'on sache ce qui est important
pour nous il faut qu'on sache ce qu'on
ne veut pas perdre et donc il faut par
exemple je peux le dire moi je ne suis
pas prête à rentrer à tunis maintenant
je ne suis pas prête ses limites pre
trade je ne dépasse pas la frontière ou
bien je peux me dire oui moi je suis
prête aujourd'hui à rentrer en tunisie
mais en tunisie je me fixe des règles
je me fixe mes limites et puis si elles
sont dépassées je réajuste ou bien je me
dis non cette limite était trop
contraignantes vu de l'extérieur ça me
paraissait bien mais finalement non je
veux les réajuster je peux je peut
l'augmenter
et au final c'est cette philosophie que
j'aimerais appliqué aujourd'hui à ce
choix
au final les métiers de l'investissement
c'est quoi c'est maximiser le rendement
sous contrainte
alors moi aujourd'hui ce que je veux
faire au final cette question ce n'est
pas est-ce que je rentre ou non ce n'est
pas la question du retour définitif mais
c'est la question de comment maximiser
mon bien-être sous contrainte
où que je sois que je sois à paris que
je sois à tunis l'important c'est de
maximiser mon bien-être et donc moi je
vais vous proposer de continuer à
échanger sur ce sujet sur la question
dure
tour définitif mais surtout à travers
cette question comment maximiser notre
bien-être sous contrainte
où que l'on soit l'accès